well oregon's neighbor to the south of
course is california and it's
experiencing a crisis tonight california
officials have just alerted residents
that they can expect quote
rotating power outages thursday evening
what the biggest state in the country
can't keep the power on
yeah because california's poured money
into renewables as part of its green new
deal
and they're not working kevin falconer
wants to fix the state of california
he's not fleeing he's going to stay and
fight he's the former mayor of san diego
he's running for governor now
he joins us tonight mr mayor thanks so
much for coming on it
this is seems like the most basic
failure of all you can't keep the power
on what is this
well thank you tucker it's great to be
back with you and you're absolutely
right it's one of the most basic
functions of a state government
and once again gavin newsom continues to
botch the basics
can't keep the lights on in california
and by the way it's not a surprise
tucker it keeps happening year after
year here
as one party rule continues to fail our
state
under things like power things like
skyrocketing homelessness you know crime
that's rising in california
once again gavin newsom has absolutely
no
solutions and telling californians
beginning of the summer and seniors
don't use your air conditioning
it's just a failure on so many levels
why do people put up with it i mean
these announcements always are
accompanied with scolding like it's your
fault
you want your house too cool you want
too much electricity
why do people keep electing gavin
newsoms to office there
well they're getting fed up uh as you as
you know all of us know out here in
california there's a reason
why two million californians signed that
recall petition that recall
is now officially qualified in
california and oh by the way
those two million folks that was
democrats republicans and independents
all folks who want a change at the top
of california because
they're tired of it they want actual
leadership and they want somebody's
going to roll up their sleeves
the types of things like we did in san
diego where we didn't allow tent
encampments
on the sidewalk the kind of governor
who's going to stand up and say it's not
okay to have the lights go off in the
summer
in the most innovative state in the
country and so yes we're fighting
to get california for that california
comeback and that's what this election
in california is going to be all about
man i hope you can do it and just the
basics like we'd like electricity we
don't want our parks to become open air
latrines
just basic stuff like you can't shoplift
it's unbelievable good luck kevin
falconer former mayor of san diego
tucker hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else